the nhs is under considerable pressure
we've had a very tough summer uh as we
have continued to treat people with
covid uh being admitted to hospitals a
society has opened up again and we've
begun to see a return to normal near
normal levels of presentations of urgent
and emergent people who need urgent
emergency care and of course as we
started to make inroads uh into
treatments for patients whose care has
been disrupted and delayed during the
pandemic so so it undoubtedly feels
exceptionally busy
in the nhs and our nhs organizations are
telling us that all the time now in
september we saw a reduction in the
number of coveted patients in hospital
down to below 5000 in england as
infection rates went down as jenny
showed you earlier uh in the last few
weeks those infection rates have gone
back up again and we have started to see
again as secretary of state has said an
increase in the number of emissions and
an increase in the number of patients in
hospital so now in england in our main
hospitals we're just over six thousand
as i stand here today six thousand
patients with covid which is back to
where we were in the middle of september
uh and i anticipate that over the next
week or two that number will increase
because infection rates are increasing
and as i've said many times there is a
lag between infection rates and hospital
admissions
now
it's not just covet of course
we
have one eye to the flu season
and we don't know what's going to happen
with flu this year but there is a risk
that we will get more flu back and it
will be worse than previous years
because we missed out a season last year
and there are other viruses uh around us
yet as well around as well and of course
we are continuing to do all that work
around uh the recovery of our elective
and routine services so it is very very
busy uh indeed
we we
work very closely with the department of
health social care around the judgment
of how the nhs is doing and we will
continue to do that as we go into winter
but i think the really critical thing is
that the public can help us here the
public can absolutely help the nhs here
and as the secretary of state has said
there are things that the public can do
that will take the pressure off the nhs
so the first is to remember that for
face masks there is guidance in place if
you are in a crowded environment a
higher risk environment on the tube you
know a building cramp building with with
low ventilation then wear that face mask
it makes a difference it really does and
the second thing of course is the
vaccine program because the vaccine
program is our best protection against
covid and therefore
if you've been invited for a booster and
you haven't had one or if you are
getting your invitation in the next few
weeks then get that booster as quickly
as possible because we know that the
immunity that we get from vaccines will
drop off over time and we don't want
that to occur going into winter so this
is not something
that we
that we just need to leave we can get
the public to help us on this and and
during the last 18 months the pandemic i
think the public has been fantastic in
responding to assist us in the nhs with
pressures and and the public can do it
again by remembering covet is still here
we need to be cautious where appropriate
and we need to get those jabs
when we're offered them